how long have you actually been Muslim
so I actually took shahada when I was in
Philippines because I got sick of
waiting I was just I was in a bathroom
in the Philippines but officially
um in in this Masjid behind us about I'd
say 10 days ago
um and one was Philippines if you don't
mind me Philippines was a couple weeks
back three weeks ago okay I just a
friend of mine who was chatting with he
said you know you can do it now you
don't have to wait to be in a Masjid so
I was just like all right let's go
I want to know your life before Islam
spiritually Okay cool so 13 years of
Catholic schooling I'll be honest church
was always a chore we used to I remember
we used to hide so we didn't have to go
to church in school
but it was it was presented as a chore
and it was always a very boring very
dull thing
having moved to the Middle East I've
been here for 15 years I've lived in
Iran Syria a lot of time in Saudi Iraq
and so on I always felt that
especially when I'd see people rushing
to the Masjid for choma prayer I I felt
they've got something I don't not in an
envious thing but just seeing you know I
see that they have a devotion and a
Brotherhood and a faith a connection
with God which I don't I always felt
something was missing in that sense but
ultimately my decision to revert I mean
it was a long time coming I was
I'd say pretty serious about my reading
for the last five years because it's not
it's not a small decision right and
there's no going back once it's done it
was not an emotional thing
um it was purely logical
and my reasoning being that first of all
if you want to get the most out of The
Human Experience why would you live
without a connection to God you know if
you if you want
to perceive Humanity with a certain
system that made you the most worthwhile
human you could be
you know to live out your Human
Experience in the best way possible to
therefore contribute the most to
humanity to your family to society and
so on
why not Islam because for me it's a lot
more than just a religion in in the
sense that to answer your question
pre-islam I thought religion was go to
church once a week
you know say a few things
understanding Islam to me it's it's so
much more than what I perceived a
religion to be before it's a system for
perceiving the world it's a system for
self-programming yourself effectively
what are you doing when you when you
pray you're giving gratitude you're
acknowledging that you are not you know
the center of the universe you're
conceptualizing things like shaytan you
know Temptation you're conceptualizing
the fact that you are accountable to a
higher Force
how does that not make you a better
human and therefore better positioned to
give value to your family to stay
disciplined to work hard for society to
me it's just in a purely logical sense
Islam is a system that makes you the
best version you can be when practiced
earnestly and therefore makes you the
most positive contributor to your family
unit to your brothers to society
how can you argue against that to me
it's overwhelmingly positive so that was
the turning point if for me personally
my main goal in life at the moment is to
be the best version of the man I can be
Islam is a is a a real accelerator of
that it really is it's a system for life
to make you the best version of a man
that you can be and I think that's I
think it's quite powerful So speaking
about connection tool guide have you
ever dealt with atheism because a lot of
people I hear this a lot I'm too logical
for God I'm too rational to believe in a
God to that I'd say atheists to me first
of all don't seem like very happy people
so that's the first one
um but secondly okay the argument for or
against God again what's your primary
purpose for being on this planet if it's
to be the best version of a man that you
can be and give the most positive impact
to your family your brothers the causes
you believe in society
then trying to do that without it
without religion without Islam you're
missing you're missing a a weapon in
Your Arsenal so atheists to me they're
shooting themselves in the foot let's
say you know somehow they are right
which obviously we know they're not
if their belief systems don't make them
fulfilled and make them the best
versions of themselves that they can be
then what's the point of their belief
system I I I would argue that logic
if you're if you can go to a mosque and
feel an intense emotional connection
with a higher power feel the Brotherhood
or the the men you're standing next to
why would you choose atheism where you
miss out on all these things to me
that's illogical so that would be my
argument there
so
how would you say that Islam has changed
the life
or benefit yeah interesting one brother
I mean it hasn't been that long
um
I feel
a lot of energy about my desire to learn
more which I quite like
um
typically learning new things can be a
bit of a chore whereas the more I read
about Islam the more I the conversations
I have the more hunger I have to learn
so I feel even more motivated I'm a
pretty motivated guy already like I work
pretty hard I feel more motivated to
carve out more time to increase my
learning definitely going to the Masjid
is I try and go every day I've I've been
successful by one day in the last couple
weeks
there's a there's a power there which I
haven't really comprehended yet
um and I I think it's simply by I mean
the phrase Allahu Akbar God is is the
biggest the greatest just by
acknowledging that and giving thanks to
me it gets your ego out of the way it
gets your problems out of the way and
yes you could say you know I'm grateful
to God for everything I've been given
you go to a Masjid and you pray that's
an action and we all know actions have
more power than words so for me I mean
one example ever since my kids were
really little before we go to bed we
always take turns saying three things
we're grateful for throughout the day
because I wanted to build that mindset
in my in my kids to be grateful
especially because growing up in in
Dubai alhamdulillah they have everything
they could ever want I wanted them to
stay stay grounded and stay grateful
tell me that going and praying isn't the
adult version of that you are
self-programming you yourself to be
grateful you were reminding yourself
that there is a higher power that you
are accountable to that higher power so
through that practice I've become even
more grateful and even more
focused on each getting the most out of
each day I I find that the the ritual of
prayer definitely adds discipline you
need to get up you know but by certain
times you know you need to I need to
learn Arabic to understand what I'm
saying better it's as a whole it's very
motivating it's given me a lot more
energy uh to approach every day there's
any belief that I have that we become
Muslim before we become Muslim like you
know you're a Muslim and you take the
shahada subconsciously before you
logically come to terms with verbalizing
the shadow because I think that's your
ego catching up with what you innately
believe when you already submit
that correlates with my experience 100
100 we've got a very special
announcement as you can see we are here
in Masjid
father Muslim Brothers
game we have our first drop coming out
soon we have 200 pieces that are going
to be released within this drought so if
that's something you're trying to do
then click the link on the screen in the
description box down below to get 10 off
on the drop day which is much 31st and
make sure to check your email box so you
can see if you got the message check
your spam folder as well to see if you
got the message like where you can be on
point and be notified as soon as we
release this clothing on my study first
five percent of all proceeds are going
to building Masjid in Norway so make
sure that you are checking your email so
that you can confirm and be notified
when we drop on March 31st collection is
going to be called Victory impatience in
honor of Andrew and Tristan Tate for
what they're going through right now so
let's make Dua so that Allah releases
them as soon as possible and brings them
out in the best state that he can
possibly bring them out in
foreign